What we want to do now, is take into
account, these two updates to Grant's
total future earnings. We know that the
first thing that happens, is that Mr.
Belvedere will triple the orders that
Grant had initially. And then after that
tripling happens, a school orders one
wiper set and two nozzles for each of its
150 students. So remember step one here
happens before step two. So taking those
two things into account what is a new
equation for Grant's future earnings? So,
in other words, how do we modify the
equation that we had before for his total
future earnings, 84w+60n, to reflect these
two changes to the number of orders that
he has, and therefore the amount of money
that he's going to make? Please choose the
best choice from these four.